après 3 ans 1 mois et 18 jours passés à
matignon edouard philippe cède la place
à son successeur
je suis un peu ému en vous disant cela
mais soyez bon et comme on dit chez moi
bon vent tel un bouclier pour emmanuel
macron edouard philippe a souvent été
exposé au cours de son mandat
la mesure de limitation de la vitesse à
80 km/heure l'a d'abord rendu très
impopulaire
puis les contestations se sont enchaînés
gilet jaune réforme des retraites
hôpital public un mandat à matignon
compliqué pour edouard philippe
jusqu'à la crise du coronavirus lors de
laquelle il se révèle au français j'ai
donc décidé jusqu'à nouvel ordre la
fermeture à compter de ce soir minuit de
tous les lieux recevant du public non
indispensables à la vie du pays
à présent retour au local pour l'ancien
premier ministre
avec plus de 58% des suffrages au second
tour edouard philippe est attendu au
havre vive qu'il n'a jamais réellement
quitté pendant ses fonctions wavre les
résultats sont nets et je voudrais
remercier très sincèrement les havrais
et les havrais qui pour continuer à nous
faire confiance
salué pour sa gestion de la crise du
coronavirus edouard philippe parent avec
une cote de popularité au beau fixe
creusant un peu plus l'écart avec
emmanuel macron l'ancien premier
ministre devrait rester en contact
étroit avec le chef de l'état qui lui a
confié une mission visant à consolider
la majorité en vue des élections de 2022
une décision qui intervient après des
élections municipales qui ont mis en
lumière la très faible implantation
locale de l air m
déjà fragilisée par des contestations
internes